Throwing indestructible lizards into vats
of acid, hunting strange chicken men through
forests in Ireland, arguing in Latin with
a man wearing a haunted Roman Centurion’s
helmet.
When you join the SCP Foundation, you might
be expecting high-octane drama all the time.
Especially with the name Street Sweepers,
you’d expect this Mobile Task Force to be
neck deep in some real action-packed street
racing.
Maybe you wouldn’t think that they’d be
tasked with driving all day every day in four-hour
shifts, tailing a semi-truck, all over Birmingham,
Alabama.
But as Agent Moore and his colleague pulled
into the layby behind the truck, neither of
them were ready for what they were about to
witness…
*
SCP-2590 was first discovered by the Foundation
at a routine traffic stop.
Investigating a totally different anomaly
in the Birmingham area, Agents Peters and
Smith had been posing as local police officers.
The Foundation had been trying to track down
an artifact that was supposedly being smuggled
across the US in the back of a non-descript
station wagon.
Peters and Smith had been allocated a pair
of beat-up old police cruisers which they’d
parked across the dirt road, fully blocking
any traffic from coming through.
It was several hours into their shift, when
the incident occurred, just at the point that
they were starting to lose focus.
Taking a look through the suitcases and memorabilia
from a family’s trip to Disney World, Peters
had taken way too long to hear the noise of
the engine swelling behind him.
He spun around to see the hulking shape of
the semi-truck barreling straight towards
him, Agent Smith, and a family of five.
With only two seconds to react, he yelled
out at the top of his lungs and dived out
of the way, leaving the trunk of the car wide
open with five screams emerging from inside.
Smith, who had been sitting in one of the
cruisers, only just managed to get out before
the semi made contact.
Eyes closed, Agent Peters waited for the inevitable
sound of screaming rubber, the bang of metal
on metal, and the shower of glass on asphalt.
But it never came.
When he opened his eyes, the station wagon
was still parked up in front of them, the
two police cruisers still blocking the road,
and all of the Disney merch still piled high
in the trunk.
The semi was driving off along the road on
the other side of their blockade, not a scratch
on it.
Without a moment's hesitation, Agent Smith,
who had kept his eyes open and witnessed the
whole thing, leaped into action.
He ordered his partner, still lying confused
in the dirt, to administer Class-A amnestics
to the family and call in for backup.
Agent Smith himself jammed his keys into the
ignition, twisted them so hard he almost bent
the metal, and took off after the vehicle.
What Agents Smith and Peters had just witnessed
was the very first Foundation exposure to
SCP-2590, fondly nicknamed Trailer Trash.
As Smith pulled up alongside the vehicle and
studied it for the first time, he made a note
of its initial appearance over the radio,
an appearance which remains unchanged years
later.
The badges on the vehicle claim that it is
an International ProStar DayCab semi-trailer
truck, complete with an unmarked trailer.
As the Agent flicked on his lights and indicated
that the vehicle should pull over, he noted
that it didn’t have any license plates on
it, either front or rear.
He leaned forward in his seat, trying to peer
into the cab to make out the driver, but in
the Alabama sun, the man just looked like
a shadowy figure.
They drove side by side along the road for
almost a mile.
The truck made no signs of pulling over despite
Agent Smith’s continued insistence and repeated
flashes of the cop lights, but it also didn’t
attempt to pull away either.
It just continued to drive a few miles per
hour below the speed limit.
The driver didn’t seem to look across at
him once.
Having discussed it with Foundation staff,
they decided that it was best not to draw
attention to the situation.
They had no idea whether this SCP was hostile
or posed any threat to civilian life, but
having blue and red lights flashing at it
appeared to be doing little to change the
situation.
Instead, he switched off the sirens and pulled
in behind the truck, tailing it around Birmingham
as the Foundation readied further agents to
respond to the situation.
For almost an hour, nothing of note happened.
Agent Smith drove behind the trailer, watching
it like a hawk.
He observed that it obeyed every traffic law
to a T. It never broke the speed limit, never
cut anyone off, and left room for other vehicles
to merge.
If hadn’t seen it drive straight through
a roadblock as if it wasn’t there, he would
never have suspected a thing.
But then the truck turned its turn signal
on.
They had just come off the highway and merged
onto a quiet side street, just as the sun
was starting to hang low in the sky.
The truck crept across to the side of the
road, squeezing its brakes gently, and stopped.
Agent Smith matched the action the whole way,
pulling up about twenty feet behind the trailer.
In constant radio communication, he kicked
open his door and stepped out into the evening
air.
Foundation personnel advised that he keep
a hand on his gun at all times and approach
with caution.
He didn’t really need them to tell him that.
Smith called out for the driver to step out
of the cab.
No response.
The truck just sat there with its hazards
on, engine off.
After a moment, there was a clunk, and the
trailer door started to slowly open, all by
itself.
Agent Smith called in backup, but they were
still several minutes out.
Instead, he ran back to the car, gun raised,
and waited to see what was inside as the door
slowly opened to reveal…
Nothing.
No, not quite nothing.
There was something small on the floor of
the trailer, right in the center, as if it
hadn’t been moved around at all by the vehicle’s
motion.
It was red.
A kind of elongated cuboid.
He reported it all to the Foundation over
his radio, then paused when he recognized
what it was.
A Kit Kat candy bar.
Or, to be more specific, a Kit Kat Chunky.
What happened after this point was hazy.
Agent Smith was found on the roadside just
twenty minutes later, confused about what
had happened.
The truck was nowhere in sight.
However, a security camera from a convenience
store just up the street happened to capture
the interaction.
In the footage, you see Agent Smith approaching
the trailer with his gun raised, looking at
the Kit Kat.
He tries to enter the trailer but is unable
to, so approaches the driver’s side door.
While talking to the shadowy figure in the
cab, he drops his gun and stands motionless,
a confused and sleepy expression on his face,
until the trailer door closes and the SCP
drives away.
Contact was reestablished with SCP-2590 soon
after and has been maintained almost uninterrupted
ever since.
The findings made on that initial encounter
seem to hold true across further examination.
Personnel has reached out to Navistar International,
the company that supposedly manufactures this
model of semi-truck, but there appear to be
no records of its creation or shipment to
the US.
In fact, no documentation at all can be attributed
to the truck or any components on it.
The driver in the front cab is a humanoid
figure who is perpetually shrouded in shadow,
designated SCP-2590-1.
Attempts to reveal the driver’s features
have proven ineffective, as even powerful
spotlights do not shed enough light into the
cab to render the driver visible.
Quite what this driver’s role is in the
operation of SCP-2590 is unknown.
SCP-2590-1 appears to have some proximity-based
amnestic qualities, as anyone approaching
it on foot has reported memory loss and confusion
soon after, just like Agent Smith.
As also discovered by the two agents and their
roadblock, containment of this SCP is simply
not possible.
While the majority of the time, the SCP is
corporeal, it possesses the ability to pass
through solid objects at will.
All attempted roadblocks have resulted in
the same thing happening, the SCP will just
phase right on through them as if nothing
was there.
Since it cannot be contained in the usual
way, a different operation has been set up
to monitor the truck’s activities which
so far have proven to be apparently harmless
to the civilian population.
Mobile Task Force Gamma 133, also known as
the street sweepers, has been established
to follow this SCP around Birmingham at all
times.
They operate in four-hour shifts, with two
agents in unmarked vehicles sticking close
behind the trailer at all times.
The Foundation was able to fit a tracking
device onto it as well, providing researchers
with continuous location data for where they
can find the vehicle.
At seemingly random times, supposedly determined
by the SCP itself, it pulls over somewhere
quiet and opens the door to its trailer.
The door will remain open for 60 seconds,
and then close again.
Any attempts to enter the trailer have been
blocked by some kind of invisible barrier,
seemingly impenetrable to most approaches.
More violent and destructive methods of entry
cannot be authorized for testing, due to the
heavy civilian population in the surrounding
area.
Every time the doors open, there is something
different in the trailer.
Researchers are trying to ascertain some kind
of pattern or messaging behind most of the
objects, but many seem to be random.
The current list of things that have appeared
in the back of SCP-2590 include an iPhone
3G, a red apple, and a lit lightbulb without
any visible form of power supply.
Most notable about the objects in the trailer
is that often they appear to be human beings,
as happened on the night that Agent Moore
was on duty in the Street Sweepers.
*
The Agents pulled in behind the truck as per
usual when it slowed to a stop beside the
highway.
Agent Moore got out of the vehicle second,
unenthused about the monotony of the task
that he had been assigned.
Expecting to see a cardboard box or a chapstick
when the trailer door opened, he was left
shocked when he came face to face with himself.
Few people can say that they have seen themselves
in real life, most of them have been administered
with various amnestics to make them forget,
but Agent Moore went on to report how bizarre
of an experience it was.
He claimed that it was utterly unlike looking
in a mirror where your reflection is flipped
and follows your every move.
Seeing yourself standing in three dimensions,
moving independently and evidently in a great
deal of distress, is an experience that few
would envy.
Any time a human being materializes in the
trailer, they appear to be in a great deal
of distress as they attempt to escape through
the invisible barrier.
Agent Moore and his partner Agent Hall could
do nothing but stand and watch in confusion
as the copy of him attempted to free himself
before, after the usual 60 seconds, the trailer
door closed, and the vehicle pulled away again.
Several instances have occurred of duplicate
humans appearing in the trailer, but each
time the ‘original’ person seems to have
had no knowledge of this taking place, and
nothing out of the ordinary happens to them.
However, there appears to be some small pattern
demonstrating the SCP has an awareness of
the Foundation as it has also duplicated Agent
Inglis’s sister, who has no connection to
this SCP at all.
Incident 16 was the most distressing of all,
as a large slab of metal appeared in the back
of the trailer with the SCP Foundation logo
painted across it.
Agents Inglis and Shultz were on duty at the
time and observed copious amounts of blood
flowing out of the metal slab.
Before long, the blood filled the back of
the trailer, pushing up against the invisible
barrier.
All of a sudden, 52 seconds into the encounter,
the barrier vanished, and a cascade of blood
with the slab inside were launched out at
the two agents at a speed of over 190 kilometers
an hour, killing them both instantly.
Since this incident, SCP-2590 has been treated
with greater caution.
The most mysterious thing to have come from
researching this truck came on December 4th,
2011, when for the first time, the truck’s
tracking beacon stopped working.
It had been seen pulling into an abandoned
warehouse and so a team of Street Sweepers
was immediately dispatched to investigate.
When they arrived, they found the vehicle
moving through the warehouse at a slow crawl.
Choosing to pursue on foot and leaving a pair
of agents at the entrance, they followed the
SCP through the facility until it came to
what agents described as a ‘service tunnel
or sewer of some sort’.
Putting headlamps on, they followed the truck
down into the tunnel, maintaining radio contact
throughout.
As they reported the direction they were traveling
and the distance, it quickly became apparent
to Foundation personnel that this was no ordinary
tunnel.
The warehouse was positioned overlooking a
cliff, and so the geography was not physically
possible.
As the Street Sweepers descended further into
the tunnel, they noted that there were increased
levels of carbon monoxide.
Radio contact started to dip in and out, losing
signal as they went further downhill.
Just at the edge of their signal with the
Foundation, the truck stopped and opened its
trailer door.
Inside was just a single piece of parchment
with the words ‘I'm just delivering a message’
written on it.
After the usual 60 seconds, the trailer door
closed, and the truck continued.
After they had passed the kilometer mark,
the radio signal worsened quickly, and after
a couple of scrambled messages, the team down
there were not heard from again.
The channel stayed open for another 6 hours
before the Foundation made the decision to
announce the agents missing in action.
In March 2015, over three years later, a radio
signal came into contact with the Foundation
again from Birmingham, Alabama.
It was from the headset of the squad leader
who had gone into the tunnel.
Initially confused as to who had gained access
to the comms channel, the Foundation demanded
that the agent state his full name and rank.
The agent, himself confused, obliged, questioning
why they were so suspicious.
He and his team claimed to have only lost
contact for about fifteen minutes.
They had followed the SCP a little further
until carbon monoxide levels had risen too
high to continue, at which point they’d
had to watched the truck disappearing into
the distance as they walked back to the surface.
All agents have undergone extensive psychological
rehabilitation to settle them back into society,
as well as classes to fill them in on things
like the London Olympics, the Ice Bucket Challenge,
and Gangnam style.
As for SCP-2590, it is back out on the roads,
roaming around Birmingham, Alabama continuously.
Never stopping for fuel, always obeying the
rules of the road, occasionally opening its
trailer doors to reveal new and bizarre findings…
Now check out “Living Ice Cream Van SCP-1386”
and “SCP-342 - A Ticket to Ride” for more!